[Music]
episode expects us to believe that rick
would help pack the car for a trip he's
not even going on are you sure rick i
know i know a cruise doesn't sound like
an adventure on paper what a cruise only
sounds like an adventure on paper all
you can eat food the ocean views random
encounters with mysterious strangers
it's only once you're on board you
realize you're trapped in a floating
bacteria prison with half-cooked salmon
the threat of death below in the rocking
waves and a dude named rusty who can't
quit telling you about how his 2001 ford
150 just crossed 300 000 miles morty i'm
trying to stay humble right now rick for
real ionic coaster deployed what does
rick need an ionic coaster for when he
has so much free space on that workbench
right next to him garage ai is just
showing off at this point approaching
paws pregnancy in p minus
it's worth mentioning every once in a
while that despite being here to sin it
the show continues to find new ways to
make me laugh so take your rick and
morty gets a sin off because it's
freaking hilarious cliche and let's move
on how can a mind be hidden by itself
inside itself the first question
christopher nolan asked before starting
every screenplay somehow makes its way
into this episode suggestion don't go in
right the ai is loose enough to offer
fellatio for its own survival but still
rigid about saying command words like
suggestion before every sentence pick a
lane shallow hal yeah yeah hop to a
different timeline grab a version of my
friend that suits me best that's not how
this works and why not exactly did rick
just place that iv in one movement with
no tie off and without looking like i
get that you can do something enough to
be good at it but even the best
phlebotomist wouldn't deign to feign the
main vein oh excellent i get to keep my
clothes i thought for sure i'd have to
be naked to go through something this
artsy why does rick care about his
clothes when is rick ever given he's
naked or clothed if you looked up down
to free ball in the dictionary it'd just
be a picture of rick saying wubble up a
dub dub now i got yolk balls title of my
sex tape no wait that was now that's
what i call yoke balls 23 my bad you see
an older version of him come through
here
talking out of just one side of your
bosom seriously you've got two jabber
jubblies use them both opening a porta
potty without knocking first why was my
ninth birthday party in a pine tree pine
tree pizza is still at least 19 better
than what they serve at chuck e cheese
so what's my deal am i sentient do i
have free will who does
covering the same ground is free guy
i'm coming with now that i know my life
is a lie wow you really are 35.
30-something shaming random convenient
pants that fit perfectly are random and
convenient and fit perfectly also
chafing can we both die in here are we
damaging our friend's brain i i don't
know any of the rules welcome to the
club the trick is just to pretend that
none of it matters and that making meta
jokes about it makes it all okay but we
suck at that so here's five cents
situation not looking ideal rick and
bird person survive this also it's bad
enough when human characters talk to
themselves as a way to force some
exposition but an ai construct what kind
of a logic chip would have to be
installed for a computer to start
thinking out loud thinking to themselves
is their whole gig i am rick's garage oh
like a like a jarvis like like jarvis
and iron man well that's a strange way
to say what the [ __ ] this garage with a
dying man hooked up to some sort of
cyborg bird creature is talking to me
also mcu nerds this is where you being
this leads you're not my fault i'm yours
this is all fun self therapy and all but
rick isn't engaging with his younger
self he's engaging with how not michael
keaton's birdman remembers his younger
self so why is argument if you join your
friend's brain you die in real life
citation needed your life isn't real and
i didn't save it take off all your
clothes but why all of his clothes real
rick already has pants on your values
are wrong facebook this battle of blood
ridge goes on for all the some time why
would you not revisit this oh i don't
know maybe uh the ending the dark knight
rises okay you matter to me oh look the
show that spent several seasons teaching
me that rick has exactly zero moral
compass and is a complete dick to almost
everyone he meets in the service of
humor is now asking me to have emotions
about this the answer is no why the [ __ ]
are you risking your life for that
[ __ ] taking the wrong message from
the lesson you don't get to tell anyone
what's sad man you're like a one-man
mount sadmore so i guess like a lincoln
sad morial i mean the statue of liberty
was right there man everyone knows what
a cloaca is do they it's not like
there's ever been a company out there
that based an entire t-shirt around one
sorry but we do not get to choose the
ones we love but we can't choose our
friends and we can't choose our noses
but we should never choose our friends
noses
wait rick sanchez you're under arrest
for making me spend two years in earth
high school i bet this show would be
really fun for people who could remember
all the details of all the other tammy
plots and i've got the memory of a
goldfish so all those callbacks mean
nothing to me actually goldfish have
been proven to have better memories than
we thought so maybe more like the memory
of a dog or a bee or a what was i
talking about again oh well make the
noise thing change the number thing oh
my god i'm a memory we just sat through
all that stand up for nothing but in a
world where you're aware of multiple
universes and multiple use why would
your first instinct be that you're a
memory when you see another rick come
crashing in okay listen everybody my
name's rick this is my new friend bird
man and his friends we all just met at
this festival and we're so high we
formed a band oddly enough this is
exactly how sugar ray was formed i'd
like to point out that this clock still
says 2pm which it said when all this
started and don't be claiming inception
rules because discount ava had plenty of
time to offer b-plot bjs to random
passers-by while they were out and yes
it could just be a dead clock battery
but that's boring and also means i
couldn't give this in
pretending prisoners have servers they
go around and dish out food to the
prisoners does this look like a
white-collar crime prison to you
get out get out of my head are you sure
you don't want to come with us oh i wish
i could but i don't want to excuse me
did i pick that name i have so many
names
i am indeed down to clown i can make
things out of clay and lay by the bay i
just made why was my ninth birthday
party in a pine tree what you were
looking at are memories
in this case pertaining to one
individual hello hi good afternoon
what i want you to think about what
you've done kent and from now on stop
playing with yourself
it is gone i need your clothes your
boots and your motorcycle we lost
germany we lost friends
if we lose today we won't get to fight
enough
i know the pressure on you is enormous
two minutes to drop